and finally new rules since it was my
million dollar check to Obama in 2012
that turned around his lagging campaign
and put America back on the path to
awesome exceptionalism tonight I would
like to announce that the time has come
for me to step forward and save Hillary
Clinton's lagging campaign by digging
down deep and forking over 1 million
dollars
worth of advice
sorry I'm acting welcome back man I live
in California I need that money to pay
my water bill now I know many Liberal
Democrats these days are expecting
Bernie Sanders to be their standard
bearer now that he's a now that he's
ahead in New Hampshire but I wouldn't
have the couches in the Oval Office
fitted for plastic slipcovers just yet I
mean I love Bernie but we must assume
Hillary is going to be the nominee and
after witnessing after witnessing the
gruesome hundred car pileup that is the
Republican field I for one I'm not going
to stand idly by and let Hillary blow
this thing and yes the situation is dire
her positives are in freefall with only
37% of Americans now viewing Hillary
favorably and 57% says she's not
trustworthy if an election were held
today she'd lose key battleground states
to Scott Walker a man who looks like a
drunk in a silent movie
who's just been punched by mistake
perhaps worst of all one poll says she's
now viewed negatively by white women
with college degrees
that's like Obama losing John Legend
Hillary I don't want to sound like Trump
but your campaign stinks and your
numbers are terrible
and speaking of Trump Hillary you should
be the one candidate who hits that
blowhard as hard as he hits say
something like mr. Trump you accused
megyn kelly of being on the rag what
what's going on with your hormones when
you start whining every time a woman
asks you a tough question you little
[ __ ]
and that's my first bit of advice you've
got to make the campaign more fun this
week you introduced a detailed plan to
make college more affordable as you've
released detailed plans on immigration
climate change taxes whatever honey that
stuff that's actually relevant to the
job of being president of the United
States but this is America campaigns
aren't for policy just say I will be the
best at college affordability and enjoy
it more a prominent supporter recently
called your campaign joyless and it kind
of is now I know this presents a
conundrum how do you appear more joyful
but without that laugh
yes the laughs the one that makes people
think you're the Wicked Witch of the
West Wing you got to get rid of that and
you got to find a way to look like
you're a spontaneous fun lover see if
Taylor Swift has room and her girl gang
for you ride an inflatable penis with
Miley Cyrus look a donut with Ariana
Grande pee in a bucket with Justin
Bieber geez girl you invented bad blood
start a Twitter war with Katy Perry and
then delete your tweets okay next
next thing you have to do I want you to
announce your VP pick and I want it to
be baltimore slap mom that's right
remember the woman during the Baltimore
riots this year who slapped her son
because he was throwing bricks at the
cops she is your ticket to the White
House liberals love her because she's a
strong single mom and conservatives love
her because she beats the crap out of
unarmed black teenager and finally
Hillary your ace in the hole to get
America back on your side is your
husband Bill Clinton
he has to have an affair
or at least you have to find a way to
publicize one of the ones he's probably
already happened I say this because the
years when you owned most admired woman
in America were the years when he was
doing with anything that had shoulder
length hair and moved slower than he did
you can get the magic back but Bill has
to humiliate you if at all possible with
rebel Wilson on the jumbotron
at a Cubs game while you're throwing out
the first pitch we can also make this
work of Jonah Hill but now all right
you